[Music]
my name is killed the new course
spilling it from Jim McLoughlin these
past two weeks due to the Cova concerns
and today I wanted to go over the
caro-kann and more specifically I wanted
to start with the advanced variation in
the Carroll Khan it's one of the most
testing lines and it's definitely where
a lot of the tricks lie for black to
deal with so to jump right in
I wanted to go over a game between
Gawain Jones and Geoffrey Zhang and this
was a game that was actually played last
year right here at the st. Louis chess
club and I believe the summer classic
this game of course started off with E
for c6 d4 and d5 this is of course you
know the the main starting position in
the caro-kann black first place c6 and
then stakes his claim in the center with
the move d5 white however gets these two
strong central pawns and will look to
use the central advantage to gain some
space and perhaps even launch an attack
against the black Kings side so today to
start with we're looking at the advanced
variation this is kind of the most
testing line against the caro-kann that
I've really found this is the one that
has given me the most problems and it's
one of the ones where white is kind of
trying to get everything you know
there's the exchange caro-kann where
white takes on d5 and here both players
end up with one real big claim in the
center there's the classical care Khan
with Knight c3 or you still get rid of
this efore pawn
why does have a small central advantage
here on d4 but it's on a half-open file
it's a little bit more easily attacked
but with E 5 white is saying I want both
of these central pawns and I want to
keep the position closed in the center
and then launch an attack perhaps on the
Kings side so today in this game
Geoffrey Zhang shows Bishop f5 and this
is the
that I'm gonna recommend it's the most
natural way to play with black and
you'll notice that we get the bishop out
before playing e6 this is the big
difference between the caro-kann and the
French now in the game
Gawain Jones shows a fairly tricky line
with the move
h4 so who thinks they see the threat if
black plays d6 who has the threat here
who knows who knows what's going on I
assume everybody knows of course with h4
white is actually making a very sneaky
threat to play the move h5 taking away
the bishops last safe square so the move
g4 here is in fact going to end up
trapping this Bishop one way or another
with all of these squares under White's
control so after H for white black
rather has to make a pretty difficult
decision there's a few options here for
black to deal with this threat really
the only thing you can't do is play e6
the move I'm gonna recommend is actually
h5 and for a long time h6 was the main
move here just getting ready to tuck the
bishop back on h7 but more recently in
modern chess I think the move h5 has a
slightly better reputation and the
reason for that is you just don't give
white quite so much space on the Kings
side against age six white can still
continue with this move g4 and then say
you drop this Bishop back white can even
begin doing things like e6000 for just a
few moments longer and doesn't give
white what he really wants in this game
going Jones shows a pretty interesting
line that is that has recently been
pretty pretty critical you chose to play
the move Bishop d3 and this at first
glance seems to be a pretty advantageous
trade for black this is white strong
Bishop the central pawns are on dark
squares and this bishop would be a
monster on d3 if not for this black but
on f5 so black is usually happy to take
off these bishops and that does remain
the case here but white has actually
achieved something in this opening and
that is if black plays the movie six
here well the move Bishop g5 is actually
going to be a pretty big annoyance for
black to deal with this bishops hard to
kick out of the g5 square
now that we've committed a tower upon to
h5 and for that reason I'm actually not
going to recommend the movie six in this
position it's the most common move it's
the most popular move and very strong
players have played it such as you know
Peter Svidler Artemyev Dave Navarro even
I'm singing the database but the move
I'm gonna recommend is the move that was
played in this game and that move is
Queen a5 check and who thinks they see
the idea of Qin a5 check after Bishop d2
what is black once if white simply kicks
this Queen away what is black trying to
do here
what is black trying to achieve why give
this seemingly unimportant check drawing
the bishop out to d2 what's what's the
purpose yeah
thiago potter has it right the move is
queen a6 here and the point for black is
white has made a lot of concessions and
pushing these pawns so far up the board
and if black can get the Queen's off the
board well then he really isn't going to
have too many problems in any type of
endgame for example if Queen takes a six
were played simply Knight takes a six
and we can imagine white develops calmly
and something like e six and well this
is going to be a pretty comfortable
position for black if anything black is
the one who stands a bit better
due to this slightly weak pawn on d4 you
can imagine c5 coming through and maybe
some pressure on this C file for black
now notably that this is a pretty common
line still for white playing Bishop d2
here but white must play the movie six
if he wants to play like this and the
point is he's getting rid of the super
far advanced central pawn which could
turn out to be weakness and breaking up
the the black piece is just a bit so the
game might continue is something like
Queen takes d3 e takes f7 check King
takes f7 C takes D 3 and now black is
still going to just simply develop but
the point for white is he still has a
couple squares black however has shown
to be doing totally totally fine in the
Sun game so that's the point of Queen a5
check the natural Bishop d2 seemingly
doesn't give black any problems because
after Queen a6 white really doesn't have
a comfortable way to avoid the Queen
trade that's why in this game white
played Knight d2 and this is a pretty
logical move now
so who once again if I can ask C's the
point why is Knight d2 a better move
than Bishop d2 in this case although
okay maybe not necessarily better but a
better try perhaps
what's the point of 92 versus Bishop d2
seems like Bishop d2 is much more
natural you gain this tempo on the Queen
but the problem of course was Queen a6
I'll give the chat a moment here give
the chat a moment
mmm okay I'm not seeing anybody in the
Czech getting it but I'm sure there's
some delay so I'm gonna give the answer
now and hopefully you guys at home have
had long enough to think the point is
after Queen a6 White has an additional
option here and yeah general gaming did
to get as well as Tarek so Queen i6
offering the Queen shade well now the
difference is this knight on D to help
support this c4 square and the move c4
is gonna be a very comfortable way for
white to avoid this trade now the queen
is just a little bit out of play
actually on a six it's not putting any
pressure on this diagonal and the
diagonal is going to stay blocked until
white decides to open it so after 92
Queen a6 is actually a little bit of a
misstep and Geoffrey song in the game
simply continued with a six white now
plays Knight f3 getting developed and
black is finally done doing this tricky
business
oh and I should mention the whole point
of Konya 5 check forcing Knight d2 well
not really forcing but baiting white
into play 92 is now of course this
Bishop can't get out to the strong G v
square this is the the nuance in Black's
place so far this Bishop being blocked
on c1 makes it significantly worse than
it would be on this g5 square so now
black is pretty much free to just
develop normally and as he did in the
game Geoffrey played 9 h6 White Castle
black now plays net f5 this is a great
square for the knight it eyes both weak
pawns in the white camp and with h5
preventing g4 this night is gonna be
pretty stable on this nice outpost white
and now tried night b3 in the game
hitting this Queen we see Queen a6 now
that white has castled he can more
comfortably prevent this Queen trade to
move like queen d1 note that if you had
tried Queen D Queen D 1 in the previous
lines we had looked at the King gets
rather stuck on the e1 square with this
white this black Queen rather prevented
castling now black simply plays Knight
d7 taking control of the c5 square
preparing to break
now after Bishop f4 Bishop e7 hits this
pawn g3 we see rook c8 preparing this
break even more c3 and then c5 and black
has more than comfortably survived this
opening and is looking at a good game
ahead which I'll take you through kind
of what happened in this game so you
just get an idea for more the middle
game plans but this is where I'm
claiming the the opening is more or less
over and so let's kind of stop and take
stock of this position and see what's
going on and see which player should be
happier with their opening decisions if
we look from the black side this is a
very strong knight on f5 it puts
pressure on h4 White has been forced to
play the move g3 to defend it it also
puts pressure on d4 which is the square
that black is kind of ganging up on now
with the move c5
his Bishop is on a perfectly natural
square on e7 this Knight is nice on d7
supporting c5 pressuring this square as
well even potentially coming into some
Queen side squares and lastly this Queen
well I guess not lastly this Queen is on
a perfectly fine square on a6 put some
pressure on this diagonal put some
pressure on a 2 and lastly the rooks and
the King are both in perfectly fine
spots black should be pretty comfortable
castling kingside in this game perhaps
after a move like g6 but he doesn't even
have to commit to that thanks to how
closed this efile is in the center so
this rook is useful this rook can later
come into the game after castles and all
of black's pieces have a purpose black
doesn't have any major weaknesses and so
black is looking to be very comfortable
meanwhile from the white point of view
honestly these Knights feel just a
little bit disjointed on opposite sides
of the board this Bishop on f4 doesn't
make a great impression either and white
is looking at some long-term weaknesses
on both sides of the board here with the
d4 pawn being slightly weak h4 ideas are
still going to be in the air you could
even imagine at a later date black
breaking with moves like f6 and g5
potentially and this Queen side is also
going to be in blacks favor due to the
placement of this queen so I think
honestly Black has nothing to worry
about here in fact I would much prefer
to have the black pieces from this
opening position and white honestly
hasn't done too much wrong so and that
goes to show you I think this is really
the best way for black to play against
this line and I think this is a pretty
comfortable position you're welcome to
disagree with me
but I quite like quite like this
position so in the game going Jones
tried a for taking a little bit more of
this Queen side space trying to relieve
some pressure on the a to pawn Geoffrey
played Queen b6 keeping an eye on some
squares that the a punch is vacated rook
a to now and Geoffrey plays a six white
finally flinches first on the c5 square
and captures here and black actually
takes this back with the bishop we're
not at all really concerned with Knight
takes bishop and Knight takes Knight
because the Black Knights are going to
have some nice squares in this game this
Knight already on a good square the
night from c5 can look at squares like
efore can look at squares like b3 and it
can potentially even reroute back to d7
to put more pressure here and come two
more squares so King g2 was played in
the game just a nice improving move and
now we see both players start to do some
maneuvering Geoffrey plays Knight f8
perhaps this wasn't the best move the
engine and I agree recommends a5 and the
point here is you simply prevent white
from playing a5 himself and take a
little bit more of a firmer grasp on
this Queen side regardless though Knight
of fate is not a horrible move by any
means white does play a 5 and now after
Queen b5 we start to see some exchanges
Knight takes Bishop rook takes Knight
and now rook e1 this Knight does come
out to g6 like I said more pressure over
here as well now Bishop e3 rook back to
c8 Bishop b6 actually Knight back to e7
so we see a little bit of a funny dance
here the night preparing to come to c6
perhaps 94 now
Queen back to t7 and rook a3 and you can
kind of see White's
play might look nice but he's actually
making no progress towards any real plan
so we see this Bishop come in to b6 but
but what does it really do see a knight
come to d4 but there's just no targets
for what for white to really target in
in this position so the game continued
rooks e4 Queen f3 Queen c8 rook d1 and
g6 a nice solidifying move this move was
kind of always going to be played
eventually be for now from white you see
castles Bishop back to c5 rook e8 and
now we see another trade and this game
eventually just kind of fizzled out into
nothing
Queenie 327 rook e1 rook c8 and you can
kind of tell that it's really Geoffrey
putting all the pressure on here with
these this tripling on the C file
unfortunately for him it was not enough
in the game after Queen f4 we simply see
a trade of the Knights and now this game
wrapped up pretty quickly with more
piece trades to come white tried this
move g4 to get at the black King but it
was not enough and we see eventually in
this repetition to end the game so this
was a really nice game by Geoffrey it
especially in the opening I want to say
his opening play was particularly
impressive and the reason for that is it
really never felt like black was under
any pressure at all in this game and I
think that's down to this nice nuance
here where you play Queen a5 check to
prevent this bishop from landing on g5 I
did see a question earlier about what's
the big deal with Bishop g5 why not just
Bishop e7 and the reason is simply
Knight f3 you definitely don't want to
be taking this bishop because the move H
takes is gonna be strong g6 is now
threatens and you're giving up a lot of
squares like this g4 is also going to
come if you play a move like g6
and this is going to be devastating so
the point is white can just let those
bishops sit
and it's gonna be a little bit awkward
for black to develop around this you
know you can leave this Bishop sitting
here but it's never really threatening
to trade on g5 and it just makes
development a little bit more awkward so
why not throw in Queen a5 check bring
this knight to d2 and keep this Bishop
planted on the c1 square with that in
mind any other questions on this game I
don't think I saw too much confusion
there so why don't we just go ahead and
take a look at the next line I wanted to
look at this was a game between alexei
Shira and anatoly karpov and it was
let's see this one was a pretty natural
development game this is the line that
I'm calling the most natural development
for both sides in the carrick on
advanced variation and if you're not
super booked up on the opening with the
white pieces as a lot of people aren't
this is probably how a lot of the games
are going to go for you I know from
personal experience a lot of my games in
the events kind of end up looking
something like this
where both sides just developed pretty
naturally and then it turns into a game
so what do I see what happened here
sheriff played efore c6 d 4 D 5 and E 5
of course entering the advanced
caro-kann Bishop f5 from black once
again I recommend this move over C 5 C 5
has a pretty good reputation these days
but I just don't trust it you know
hanging your pawn like that how dare you
just develop your Bishop Knight f3 in
this game like i said just natural
development white brings his pieces out
black plays e6 opening up this bishop
white brings this Bishop to e2
supporting this Knight and getting ready
to Castle now c5 and in a moment we're
going to look at the main line of the
short variation which is a little bit
more testing and that happens after
Bishop e3 but in this game I just wanted
to examine castles as sheriff played now
knight c6 puts more pressure on the D
pawn we see c3 now it in exchange on d4
n IG e7
and what we see here is the situation in
the center is already pretty clarified
like just developed his pieces to
natural squares he's going to continue
to do so and black is now also bringing
out his pieces to their most natural
squares we see a three and now actually
at night c8 from anatoly karpov the
point here being you can reroute to the
queenside from c8 and you're clearing
off this east 7 square for the Bishop
Knight bTW - Bishop e7 now we see b3 and
simply a5 and already I think white has
not given black any trouble at all in
this game continued with Bishop b2 this
Knight actually comes out to a7 perhaps
not the square you're expecting but does
support the Queen's side from here now
we see rook e1 and castles and Knight f1
from white is preparing to reroute and
put a little bit more pressure on this
Bishop we are still kind of in the
opening here but I wanted to pause once
again and kind of take stock of what's
going on once again this game I'm
calling the normal development type of
game here where White has really just
brought his pieces out to two national
squares and we're back with the board
why does really just brought his pieces
out to two natural squares and the point
is if white simply does this black can
take his time bring his Bishop to you
the best square bring out the knight do
this funny little dance with his Knights
bring this tonight back to b6 or up to
a7 is also fine and just develop as
pieces and what you end up with is
usually a position that looks like this
where the C file is open there's some
possibilities for both sides on the
Queen side and you're neither King is
really in danger so the point I'm trying
to get across is don't panic if your
opponent plays some natural looking move
that you didn't actually prepare for
specifically you just develop your
pieces and more than likely you're gonna
end up with a perfectly fine position
Karp opted in this game now Karpov
simply brings this truck out to see it
getting on the Open File 93 hits the
Bishop Bishop g6 moves the bishop now
Queen d2 Queen b6 and we see that black
is already putting some pressure on
these ponds and once again the dark
squared Bishop for white doesn't really
leave a good impression it's kind of a
recurring a recurring problem for white
in this advanced caro-kann Bishop d1 now
was White's choice trying to defend this
pawn and Karpov plays in karpova in
style very naturally rook c7 guarding
some squares and preparing to double age
four now threatens to trap the bishop so
h6 comes on the board rookie - of course
Karpov continues with this plan and
doubles and we see from here black
played a very nice game taking total
control of this C file and Karpov does
eventually manage to convert this into a
full point rook III comes on the board
now Knight b5 finally this night from a7
makes a bit more sense hitting some key
squares ninety two guards some key
squares ninety seven and now Knight h2
from white is slightly odd looking
perhaps he's just preparing some ideas
like this opening up this diagonal a
little bit more as well and this Knight
can even come back to f1 in some cases
as well as up to g4 with some attacking
ideas Ric c6 by Karpov is guarding some
squares on this sixth ring it's slightly
strange though
I think this move is it's fine but maybe
not the most useful Knight g4 now it
does threaten some things Queen d8 is
car pops choice bring the Queen back to
help defend just a bit rook h3 from
white now Queen f8 from black and this
is a very nice maneuver by it by Karpov
actually the Queen on the f8 square is
doing a great job covering all these
dark squares but in addition to this
it's also going to be putting a ton of
pressure on to a3 and
is what ends up giving Karpov a pretty
nice edge here no way to defend this
pawn so white must move it to a for now
Knight a3 comes on the board and this
once
funny-looking night that danced from g8
to e7 to c8 to a7 has come now all the
way to the a3 Square and it's putting
some nasty pressure onto white things
like night c2 might be coming with night
before to follow and even 93 and we're
well on our way to commit to completing
a night store rather than allow that to
happen
white actually captures this night on
the a3 but now after takes these squares
have been softened up considerably and
Karpov manages to eventually invade rook
g3 puts more pressure on this King
but now h5 keeps this pawn from coming
any further keeping things a bit more
closed 93 Bishop b2 is hitting this rook
or k2 is forced now Bishop c1 and Karpov
is making use of this c-file Queen g5
comes on the board Queen B 4 from Karpov
and you see now he's inching closer
preparing to invade Knight f4 from
alexis fear of is actually a critical
mistake and after Bishop takes c3 fe3
rook c1 she robbed is simply losing this
game this Bishop is falling Knight takes
g6 is not enough Karpov takes this
Bishop King h2 when we take back here
Queen takes g6 and now Queen e7 and
Karpov is this simply up a piece they
played a few more moves
rook f2 Queen takes h4 check and after
the second rook felt Alexis year of
simply resigned and Karpov won the game
in the caro-kann so what's the point of
this game what should you take away from
the opening well the point is the
advance Cara Khan is not so scary in
most cases when white doesn't play a
very very few specific lines if he just
develops naturally well then both sides
simply get developed and black does not
have anything to worry about
the goals here for black are normally
just to control the see file get a lot
of pressure on the C file going and make
sure you don't get checkmated in the
meantime that's really White's only hope
for a advantage in this line is if
somehow someway he gets some type of
checkmate going
we saw sheriff go for it in the game
bringing both these Knights forward and
even this rook up but it's just not
enough if you pay really close attention
and make sure to not blunder anything
okay was this a blitz game I don't
believe so although they might have been
in some time pressure but by the end
moving on from here this of course was
what I was calling normal development
and the key difference that we're gonna
look at in the next game is in this
position white castled allowing black to
play knight c6 in the next game it's
going to be the main line of the short
variation which is perhaps the best line
for white in modern day chess theory
where white goes Bishop III so let's
jump to that game now this was a game
between Dimitri Yaakov anko and Pavel a
Leonov this game of course started in
the Carroll Khan let me flip the board
so you see it from the black point of
view efore c6 d 4 D 5 e 5 Bishop f5 once
again now like I said it's gonna look
pretty similar to the previous game with
natural development but now here white
plays this move Bishop e3 of course in
the previous game white played King side
castles so what is the difference here
well the bishop on e3 of course is
pressuring this pawn on c5 so black no
longer has the time to play a move like
knight c6 we have to make decisions
immediately and there are a couple
options here actually in my personal
games for most of my career as Cara Khan
player I have played the move C takes d4
when after Knight takes d4 you play 97
and this is a pretty forcing way of
playing and black is doing fine
from what I've found from my personal
caro-kann study from my own repertoire
but lately I've realized like just has a
bit more fun with the move Queen
v6u defend this pawn once again and you
put some nice pressure on to the b2
square now White's main option by far is
the only one we're gonna look at here
that is Knight c3 and now you have a
kind of a funny position Queen takes b2
has been tried before but I think white
actually does get quite a nice advantage
here perhaps not from the line you would
expect the move here is actually gonna
be Queen B 1 a pretty strange-looking
move if black there is to take this
knight on c3 we're gonna get met with
Bishop d2 when this Queen is absolutely
trapped and has to sacrifice itself if
you go out to a 3 instead well Queen
takes b7 and you're losing your entire
rook it does not feel good so instead
much more common is either Queen before
or queen takes b1 when after rook takes
b1 in a move like c4 in this circus
invading on b7 pretty uncomfortable
stuff all of that is to say the point of
Queen b6 isn't so much to directly
capture this pawn on b2 but rather to
help support the pressure on d4 without
committing this pawn to actually
capturing so now after Queen b6 Knight
c3
black is totally fine playing the move
knight c6 once again and what was the
point of all this well we avoid these
nasty lines where this Knight comes out
to d4 and we don't have the option to
take it off the board this is why we
want to put the knight on c6 before
capturing to avoid this annoying Knight
d4 so that's why Queen b6 Knight c3 96
I'm gonna say is just a better line for
black in most cases now white can play a
couple moves here King side castles is
totally possible and now we might just
actually take this pawn on b2 since
we've developed our Knight you can also
just play a simple move sorry like c4
clarifying the position in the center
and going for some Queen side pressure
as you would in kind of a French defense
kind of the same
same plans as the French here instead
though in this game Yakko venko played
the move Knight a for this move attacks
the Queen so I'm gonna recommend you
move it
this move is check so I would recommend
that one feels good to play checks of
course why it's only reasonable move
here is to play c3 defending the knight
and blocking the check and now I'm gonna
recommend the move c4 here for black and
this is the move that really clarifies
the structure of the game and is showing
what black is committing to so what's
going to happen here
well black has given up his pressure on
the d4 pawn largely because white has
done everything in his power to defend
this pawn supporting it no fewer than
four times what he gains by playing the
move c4 is a little bit more control of
these light squares this Bishop can now
never really come to the d3 square he
also gains some nice queenside space on
this B 3 square as well and it also
lastly prevents white from playing C for
himself pressuring the center so after
c4 once again the plans are really going
to revolve around the Queen side for
black so expect black to look for moves
like b5 in b4 later in the game this is
how black creates some weaknesses for y
it creates some annoyances as well that
he's going to have to look out for
excuse me so yeah c4 a pretty nice move
to clarify the structure once again it
kind of reveals blacks hand that he's
going to be playing for b5 and B 4 we
see castles and black wastes no time he
plays simply b5 right away now this
Knight has nowhere to go
besides the c5 square and after Knight
c5 black is actually quite happy to take
this night off the board and go for this
change in structure so now White has a
couple pawn weaknesses to deal with and
this b4 move to look out for what has he
gained well he has this nice d4 square
so we'll see in the game he immediately
makes use of it with
they d4 black has a few options here
they're actually two games in this line
to date Knight takes d4 was played in
one of the games which is totally fine
for black a six was played in this game
which keeps a little bit more pieces on
the board and keeps a little bit more
opportunities alive I think for both
players rather than exchange these
Knights which kind of clarifies things
just a bit now this Bishop is really a
tall pawn but it's a very very useful
pawn so not too bad for white at all
instead a six in this game and white
plays the move f4 trying once again to
go for this type of Kings side pawn
Storm King side attack and as I said
earlier this is really the main way that
white is going to try to fight for an
advantage black is going for this play
on the Queen side if white wants to win
he needs to counter-attack on the Kings
side and that's what's going on here
so after f4 white or black plays a
pretty nice move here the move Bishop b4
and now I will say the computer just
wants to play b4 immediately and this is
pretty natural you simply just gang up
on the seat throne c3 pawn as quickly as
possible and for example after g4 Bishop
b4 anyways you can take on c3 next so
Queen d2 defends it takes and takes and
this is just going to be a pretty
pleasant position for black after in
exchange like this now that White has
committed to so many weaknesses on the
Kings side we're a little bit happier
taking this Knight off the board
relieving some pressure on the f5 square
and highlighting these weak pawns for
for white in the game though
Bishop e4 first I think is a really nice
a prophylactic move I'm not gonna get
mad at this move it steps out of the way
of g4
so now after g4 black can play any move
he really desires submission before
Queen d2 from white is supporting this
pawn and also supporting the King side
attack black simply castles here we're
not super afraid of White's pawn storm
really
Bishop i3 comes on the board for white
forcing this bishop to make a decision
in the game black simply captures and
after takes we finally get this b4 move
into play and black really does just
have a comfortable advantage here the
white play on the the Kings side is just
a bit too slow and with this Queen side
advantage in space for black b4 is a
really really nice move to activate all
of this pieces we saw rook h3 in the
game black went for pawn takes c3 and
after pawn takes c3 rook aviate I will
note that the computer really wants
black to take on d4 and all of these
positions and go for this position with
this bishop stuck on this square I don't
think it makes a huge difference as we
saw in the game now after Queen c2 black
plays h6 I actually would have preferred
to see the move g6 here it does weaken
the dark squares a bit more but it does
control f5 quite comfortably now Knight
takes c6 is played and Knight takes c6
white brings more pieces to the Kings
side trying to attack but it's simply
much too slow
when a3 comes on the board and there's
not much white can do about blacks
invading here so f5 is played trying to
go for checkmates but now rook b2 Queen
d1 and Queen takes c3 and this is far
from the boring caro-kann that the chat
seems to think the the opening is about
you are going for a winning advantage on
the Queen side at the expense of your
King allowing this scary-lookin attack
but this is pretty typical for the
caro-kann actually and also typical for
the caro-kann is ending up winning the
game of course Queen takes c3 has
actually allowed a tactic Bishop c1
attacks both the rook and the Queen but
because Black has gained so much so far
on the Queen side it's actually totally
fine going for this endgame here down
the exchange up
Apple ponds and with plenty of
weaknesses to attack into very mobile
connected passers on D on the DNC files
so Queen takes B to f6 is White's choice
to break up this structure this is
another reason why I would have liked g6
a bit better just keeping an eye on f5
and now Queen d4 check let me see a
trade getting rid of these checkmating
ideas for white F takes G 7 King takes G
7 now in Rick G 3 is a Czech king age 7
and I won't bore you with all the
endgame details here but we will see
that in the ends black managed to win by
using these two pawns getting the rook
and then winning a up a full piece here
so another good game for Pavel Ilyana
another good game for the caro-kann so
what was the points of this game that I
wanted to show well this is more or less
the main line of the advanced caro-kann
that I've arrived I here this is what
for a long time the grandmasters
considered to be a White's best chance
at getting an advantage and I just
wanted to show that with some nuance to
play with this Queen b6 idea we're
really not giving Wyatt
any of what he wants with this opening
line white wants to plant this knight on
d4 and put some pressure onto this
Bishop on f5 now with Queen b6 Knight c3
knight c6 we don't allow that we simply
take control of this square before why
it's Knight ever lands on it and this is
going to be a pretty comfortable game
for black other things to keep in mind
not a for this check and now c4 from
black is the idea that I'm recommending
with the plan of playing b5 be for later
and invading on the Queen side as we saw
black do in this game once again thing
is to look out for this King side attack
this is always always always going to
have to be on your mind you might get
attacked
if White's really good you might get
attacked a lot but do not fear the caret
Khan is not refuted yet you should be
able to hold if you play well so C 4 B 5
B 4 in a King side attack that's what
you can expect from this line in the
okay for the last game of the day I'm
going to take a look at a game between
Alexander Chris Kirk and Evgeny Barea
this is another game in the advanced
caro-kann of course II for c6 d 4 D 5 e
5 Bishop f5 and now Knight to c3 who is
familiar with this line who knows what's
coming up next
who knows what White's idea is I'll play
one more move I'm gonna recommend a six
the most natural move for black
what's White's idea here in the boring
caro-kann in the boring caro-kann
what is white doing with this move
Knight c3 I'll give you a hint
there are about 1700 games in the
database here 1695 of them have all
continued with this next move so this is
the point someone in the chat says the
move
g3 I am going to assume that's a typo of
course not g3 but g4 hitting the bishop
this is the classic Shirov attack in the
caro-kann and long time lecture
followers longtime Caleb Denby fans will
know I taught a lecture on this opening
from the white side already so now we're
gonna take a look from the black side in
this game and see what black does to
kind of counter and counteract this
pretty scary pretty testing line from
white so g4 hits the bishop we're gonna
drop this Bishop back to g6 now h4
immediately is actually a little bit of
mistake who can find the best move for
black after h4 why is H for a mistake
what's wrong with the move h4
there's something horribly horribly
wrong here
terribly wrong with the move age floor
ah Euclidean I believe I've actually
done a game review on one of those games
if it hasn't come out already it might
have not I'd have to double-check look
for that in the coming days yeah there
were some really good Carroll con games
and that's how to uh steel tournament
yeah of course the chat hasn't now h5 is
a great move the point of this move is
it forces g5 more or less and after g5
White's King side attack is actually
going to be completely dead this is a
crucial idea to keep in mind with both
sides of this type of caro-kann opening
where if you lose control of the f5
square if you've played both g5 + e5 as
white or if you can force your opponent
to do this as black it's going to be
very very good for the black pieces you
can now simply plant your pieces onto
this at five square for example 97
Bishop e3 and now even knight Knight f5
immediately is perfectly fine and
there's no way to open up files on the
Kings side for for white anymore you
just simply cannot do it which is why h4
is not the move in this game night GE 2
is the move and the point is now after
c5 white plays h4 of course this allows
the move h5 this is the line I'm gonna
recommend for black as well I do want to
stop though and talk about the move c5
once again before moving on to h4 of
course white is going crazy on the Kings
side so what is black do well it's the
classic principled approach to chess you
counter an attack on the flank with an
attack in the center so look for black
to be ignoring the king side as much as
he as much as he can and counter
attacking in the center of course you
can't ignore the immediate threats on
the Kings side in all cases but this is
kind of going to be the theme of this
line black needs to strike back in the
center in order to be fast enough to
deal with this King side pawn rush so c5
immediately puts pressure now we see h4
from white once again threatening to
trap this bishop so h5 from black but
what's different now for
white well now he doesn't have to play
the move g5 he has this nice move Knight
f4 hitting both of these things now of
course if you capture this white will
capture on g6 and this is just
absolutely terrible
for black never play this instead we
need to save this Bishop from capture
because this fracturing of the pawns is
simply devastating so the main move here
is Bishop h7 and this is the line I'm
gonna recommend as well it's the line
the barea have played in the game now
the obvious downside to this is this
pawn is no defended zero times and
attacked once twice even three times if
you count the Queen so of course white
can capture it and that's what we see
white do in this game now if you've been
paying attention or countering the
attack on the King side with an attack
in the center so whenever white isn't
making immediate threats that we have to
solve in the Kings side look for black
to play in the center as he does here
pawn takes d4 immediately played now
white could recapture with the Queen
this is a possibility you would expect
then just nice e6 it should be five and
a move like ninety seven and things are
actually calming down just a bit
you know what black is is finishing
development and this Queen being on d4
it doesn't really change much instead
white goes for a slight improvement here
with the move Knight b5 in to recapture
on d4 with the knight allowing this
bishop some more freedom so it doesn't
have to commit to the B 5 squared quite
so quickly now knight c6 is the natural
way to play putting pressure in the
center or counter attacking in the
center keep that in mind Knight takes d4
now black simply develops with Knight g
e7 once again and white plays a little
bit of a sideline here I will talk about
the main move which is c3 at this point
black has a few options I'm actually
gonna recommend the most testing line
which is Knight takes e5 black goes up
upon and well sorry black doesn't go up
upon like regains his pawn except now
he's traded his h5 pawn for an e5 pawn
which is going to be a favorable trade
so black now has way more control in the
center
all he has to do is consolidate get his
pieces developed and protect his King so
expect to see more like Bishop g5 here
play move like Queen c7 stepping out of
the pen and perhaps this check could be
played this is one of the main lines you
can develop your Knights finally and
white is gonna go a little bit crazy on
this Kings side but black should be
doing just fine here okay that's not
what was played in the game though
instead of c3 here we see rook h3 and
this is a pretty interesting way for
white to play rather than just play the
move c3 he's aiming to develop this rook
and honestly put it anywhere on this
third rank there are situations when you
could consider it being useful on b3
hitting b7 there's situations where it
could be useful on f3 hitting f7 even
situations where if black dares to take
this pawn it could be useful on e3 with
some potential sacrifices on e6 or h3 a
really interesting move from Alexander
Grichuk just giving his rook a ton of
options the move a six was played in the
game keeping an eye on this B 5 square
now Bishop g5 comes on the board by
White's putting more pressure on the
black pieces but now simply Queen b6 by
beriev and black is getting developed we
see Knight takes c6 played in the game
Knight takes c6 and now after Bishop d3
there is a trade of bishops not Queen
takes d3 other but rook takes d3 by
crook and black is doing it totally
totally totally fine here and black is
doing so fine that perhaps he can
actually get a pretty nice opening
advantage here with the move Queen takes
B - the idea being this pawn is hanging
with check if white isn't careful and
black is just going to go up some early
material now in the game black was a
little bit less ambitious went for the
move Queen b4 check which allows the
move c3 this of course interferes with
the Queen's access to e5 we could still
take on b2 but if we're gonna take them
b2 we should have done it on the
previous turn so now Mariah's idea was
actually just a play Queenie 4 check
when after rookie three queen g2 well I
can now even get a queen trade whenever
he wants and black is the one with the
upper attacking hand what more can you
ask for from the caro-kann Black is
attacking so Rick c1 comes on the board
can we see Quincy one check King deep to
note if king e to this of course is
hanging so king d2 and now black is
taking on f2 as well Rickey to going
back to c5 and black has collected a
pawn and this King is looking a little
bit silly on the D 2 square on the game
continued with Queen a4 rook c8
rook F 1 rook c7 a nice little maneuver
to get some seventh ranked defense King
c1 is finally tucking this King away and
Square where it belongs and now the move
d4 and this is kind of the the final
position I really want to talk about in
regards to the opening this is a really
nice way to break things open for black
as always the theme of the game once
again white attacks on the Kings side
black counter-attacks in the center in
the share of attack and d4 is a classic
example of that he's not afraid to open
things up in the center that's where he
wants to play so d4 breaks down the
whites king position and this is an
important break to keep in mind not just
in positions where there's a king on c1
but in other positions as well this is
how black can very nicely continue his
play in the center gain control of d4
and then push that pawn forward it's a
really nice idea rook d1 was played in
the game creating a threat of course
this move would be a little bit
devastating don't want to play like that
but now though simply rook d7 breaks
this pin and breaks this pin we see Rick
Edie - and now simply queen takes e5 and
Black has won the battle of the opening
he's won the center and he's going to
win the game as well C takes d4 was
played now we see Queenie for hitting
some stuff Queen c2 simply F 6 is
forcing this Bishop back and now Bishop
d2 b5 Queen takes a 6 Knight takes d4
and it's looking a lot like checkmate
rook c8 check was played King f7 tux
this King away nicely Knight g3 Queen
takes g4 rook G 192 check see Knight
takes Queen takes and now after rook d1
I should be for and things are just
falling apart quite simply Queen c6 we
see a check you can see - we see a check
King b3 let me see a check and
resignation from Alexander Grisham so
this is the last game that I wanted to
to go over here King looks silly yet you
got that right so let's do a brief
little review of this game see what
happened there is some a few key moments
that I want to stress so here of course
white does not play H for allowing age
592 is his idea
you can only play at age 4 once you're
sure that after age 5 you don't have to
play this move g5 this is the worst case
scenario for white so we see c5 now F in
black you immediately counter-attack in
the center against the King side attack
h4 makes an immediate threat so black
responds on the Kings side now after
you're the knight move our bishops hit
immediate threat on the Kings side so we
respond now Knight takes pawn no
immediate threat on the Kings side we
take in the center Knight b5 no threat
on the Kings side we attack the center
the Knight takes d4 no threat on the
Kings side we develop a piece towards
the center right rook h3 and then the
move a 6 and you might say well how can
a 6 possibly be aimed at controlling the
center where you're preventing Bishop b5
which will loosen your control of the
center so there you go
Bishop g5 Queen b6 attacking the center
tonight takes Knight takes attacking the
center you're beginning to see a theme
here I hope Bishop d3 Bishop takes now
Queen before check when the best move
was of course Queen takes b2 attacking
the center and that's really the the
point of the share of attack here white
goes all out on the Kings side as
quickly as he can but it's just not ever
going to be enough because black should
to attack in the center where it matters
all right any last-minute questions on
this Carrick on advanced variation the
point of this lecture is hopefully to
get you fully ready for the advanced
variation of the Kara this is one of the
most testing variations it's one of the
ones that gives black the most trouble
and I think I've gone over just about
every hugely critical line that you
absolutely need to know to get ready to
play this other than that thank you very
much for watching this episode of chess
openings explained be sure to stay tuned
now I believe an episode of tactics time
is coming your way or it's gonna be an
interesting one it's not gonna be a
normal chess one I'm gonna go over some
tactics in the variants get your brain
to do some lateral thinking thank you
all very much and I will see you next
time
[Music]
you
[Music]